it's tried to steal it because he knew  he couldn't out jump de'andre  got away with it and lucky for the sun  they re-jumped six-second differential  between the shot clock  and the game clock and remember  you're in the bonus as well  paul a little dribble hesitation  baseline pull up  got it and it's jammed up  clutch well a teammate came off the  bench to celebrate and took his shoe off  he's looking at the rookie  the vets with the knock down jay  his teammates so excited they jump out  and they give him a flat tire  this is why you get chris paul because  he can always get his shot  and he's not afraid the moment's not too  big a little hesitation a little step  back  look at that eight is right there for  the tip if he does miss  see gary ran right into the screen and  now it's there's no pressure coming from  behind